I think there's a lot of existential
angst, and psychedelics have
for millennia represented
hope in transition moments.
Erica Dyck is a professor at the
University of Saskatchewan who
studies the history of psychedelics
with a special interest in the
legacy of Humphry Osmond, the
British born psychiatrist who
coined the term "psychedelic,"
gave Aldous Huxley his first
dose of mescaline and conducted
pathbreaking work using LSD
to help alcoholics stop drinking.
Among Osmond's best known patients
was Bill W., the co-founder
of Alcoholics Anonymous.
Reason sat down with Dyck at the
Psychedelic Science 2023
Conference held in Denver this June,
where a reported 13,000
people gathered to talk about all
aspects of today's psychedelic
renaissance.
We talked about why drugs such
as MDMA, psilocybin and LSD
are making a comeback.
How tensions are rising between
indigenous people and medical
practitioners and whether
prohibitionists have finally
lost the war on drugs.
What does this psychedelic
renaissance mean to you?
I am a historian who's been studying
the psychedelics for over
20 years.
And so the "psychedelic renaissance"
is actually kind of a confusing term
because it's quite new, and yet
it invokes this sort of deep history
and this really deep cultural
transformation.
And as a historian, I guess I'm
a little bit nervous about that as
to whether or not we've really
reached that point where we can call
this a renaissance moment.
But I'm also really curious about
what it means in terms of what we're
trying to revive and
what we're trying to resurrect from
the past that might be worthwhile
in terms of sort of charting a
psychedelic future.
And I think there's rich opportunity
to think about some of the different
ways that psychedelics and
psychedelic thinking has really
come to bear meaning in this
historical moment.
Well, let's talk about the
you know, LSD was synthesized
in 1938.
You know, started getting used about
60 years ago, right?
43, whatever.
I'm an English major.
I know right?
But
then in the fifties and sixties,
there was this first moment where
psychedelics were being used in a
wide variety of contexts for a wide
variety of reasons.
What are the lessons that we should
be learning from that moment?
Yeah. This kind of awakening moment
when the word "psychedelic" was
first coined and kind of coalesces
around a bright a variety of
medical experimentation is this
awakening moment, I think, for
psychedelics in the 20th century.
And yet there were lots of
challenges in that moment prior to
the kind of countercultural uptake
of these substances as well.
Challenges in how to measure
experience.
Who is experience as matter?
Who should we draw those experiences
from? Whether it's indigenous
communities or midwives
or even spiritualists and people
working on paranormal questions
with respect to psychedelics.
And I think we haven't really
answered that question.
And then as psychedelics moved
underground, those questions lay
dormant. And there's a tendency, I
think, to kind of push against
the past and suggest that, you know,
now we're doing it anew or
in a fresh way.
But I like the concept of
renaissance that also reminds us to
think about what we missed in
the past and maybe resurrecting some
of those pieces. So I think that
kind of wild landscape
for experimentation of the 1950s
is something we should embrace here
again.
Can you talk about Humphry
Osmond, who's the guy who coined
the term psychedelic,
you know, skipped around the globe,
ended up in Canada, where he was
doing a lot of this work.
What is his contribution
or what is his role to
the psychedelic, I guess,
moment in the fifties?
But then what should we be learning
from him now?
Humphry Osmond is such a fascinating
character, you know, not only for
deeply investing in the word itself
"psychedelic," which is, you know,
"to bring light to the psyche"
or Delos, "to bring to light"
or introduce it in 1956
by saying "to fathom hell or
angelic, you'll need a pinch of
psychedelic." The first uttering
of it.
It's like an advertising jingle.
It is a bit. And he played around
with this concept and you can find
different rhyming couplets online.
And Aldous Huxley, his
friend, came up with his own sort of
matches.
But, you know, I think when I
interviewed Humphry Osmond in the
early 2000s,
the conversation around psychedelics
was quite different at that time.
And, you know, he wasn't getting his
phone wasn't ringing off the hook.
But, you know, I asked him what
his sort of proudest
moment was or what he thought his
legacy might be.
And these are always awkward
questions for people, I think, at
the best of times. But what
he told me was surprising.
He said that he was really proud
of helping to found Schizophrenics
Anonymous.
Hmm.
And I've been reflecting on that for
some time and wondered whether this
was because he didn't want to talk
about psychedelics in that moment
because they were considered taboo.
But I actually think there's more to
it.